we had a teacher walkout for example uh
we weren't paying our teachers what
market was so i gave our teachers a pay
raise to bring them up to market uh
government when government won't fix
itself they government always wants to
spend more so bringing that fiscal
discipline i believe in smaller
government i believe in lower taxes so
bringing some of those disciplines into
our state budget and running government
like a business
is kind of what i what i focused on we
there's 33 000 state employees in
oklahoma it's a 22 billion dollar budget
and normally they people hire
non-business people and people that have
never signed paychecks never set a
vision and hired the right people held
people accountable so those are all the
things that we brought to oklahoma
i'm dave rubin and as you guys know i'm
off the grid for all of august but we
pre-taped a bunch of interviews for you
before i left the internet and joining
me today is the governor of oklahoma
governor kevin stitt welcome to the
reuben report
hey great to be with you thanks so much
hope you're having a great time on your
vacation when this is aaron
i hope that i'm having a great time too
not paying attention
to the news but i am looking forward to
chatting with you because we met a
couple weeks before i went off the grid
governor desantis held a little event in
florida for some governors and some
twitter personalities or whatever the
rest of us are uh and you you brought up
a couple interesting points and i
immediately went up to you after i said
we got a chat so so here we are so
before we do anything uh you know people
talk about oklahoma and most people
probably say hey what what's going on in
oklahoma i don't know much about
oklahoma uh so first why don't we just
get a little your personal history and
then we'll dive into some of the stuff
we need to know about oklahoma
absolutely well i'm the 28th governor of
the great state of oklahoma fourth
generation oklahoman and a business guy
i was never in politics when i ran in
2018.
my story i grew up in norman oklahoma
where the university of oklahoma is
my dad was a pastor there and then uh
but i went to oklahoma state in
stillwater for college got an accounting
degree
and then
started my company shortly after college
with a thousand dollars in a computer
and and lived the american dream story
today we have sixteen hundred employees
uh do business all over the country and
uh i got inspired to run i watched a
businessman uh get elected president of
the united states
and uh and and i saw my state kind of
struggling and i looked and saw who was
running it was just
more of the same really just career
politicians and and i said hey if
anything's going to change we need
business people we need a fresh set of
eyes we need people like our founding
fathers and vision that we're going to
leave the private sector go serve their
country or their state and and actually
change things and focus on the next
generation not the next election and so
i told that to oklahomans when i
campaigned they agreed with me
we won the election and today oklahoma
is really exploding in growth we have uh
so many great things going we've got the
largest savings account we've ever had
we have the lowest unemployment i cut
taxes last year more people are moving
to oklahoma than ever before we're top
10 in the country in that and so things
are just really on the up and up for our
state we're the 28th largest state uh
population-wise right above uh texas
figurally and uh actually right above
texas so i like to point that out
so i think a lot of people watching this
are probably going wait a minute
oklahoma it can't have that many
problems that a successful business guy
has to run i mean we talk about
california's problems we talk about new
york's problems maybe illinois problems
i mean mostly blue state problems
what could possibly be going on in
oklahoma that is a successful guy i mean
you were running a multi-million dollar
business would have to throw his hat in
the ring well when i when i say what i'm
talking about we had a teacher walkout
for example uh we weren't paying our
teachers what market was so i gave our
teachers a pay raise to bring them up to
market uh government when government
won't fix itself they government always
wants to spend more so bringing that
fiscal discipline i believe in smaller
government i believe in lower taxes so
bringing some of those disciplines into
our state budget and running government
like a business
is kind of what i what i focused on we
there's 33 000 state employees in
oklahoma it's a 22 billion dollar budget
and normally they people hire uh
non-business people and people that have
never signed paychecks never set a
vision and hired the right people held
people accountable so those are all the
things that we brought to oklahoma and
so
things are moving
moving the needle we've deregulated our
business
setting a level playing field not
picking winners and losers so people
understand
uh
you know the great things about moving
to our state energy policy we have an
all-above energy approach and that's led
to
the lowest cost of electricity to
business or consumer so keeping those uh
conservative values going even in a red
state like ours sometimes the
bureaucracy and the government can get
away from you and you've got to come in
with an outsider to bring it back and
check
i heard you talk a bit about this a
couple weeks ago but how did you deal
with all the the lockdown madness and
figuring out what to do and allowing or
not allowing people to live their lives
accordingly
well you know first off we believe in
freedoms in oklahoma and we believe in
our constitution and we're not going to
put our constitution in the attic
just because somebody in washington dc
says that we should do that
you know so we kept our state open the
entire time i kept our schools open i
wasn't going to
uh say this business is essential and
this business is not essential the only
non-essential business is one that you
didn't put capital in or you don't get
your paycheck from so picking winners
and losers like that uh to me is
un-american it's not right and what
we've done to our businesses and then
what we did to our kids by keeping them
out of school in these other states it's
just it's an atrocity so uh in oklahoma
we kept everything open and and because
of that now people are realizing and
recognizing the benefits our businesses
are are having their best years ever and
companies from california are moving to
states like ours uh because they they're
tired of the mandates and the and the
dictating from the holier-than-now
government officials that we know best
and and do as we do as we say so i think
uh everyone watching knows my story and
you heard it at that event we did i am a
new floridian about seven months in
right now after living in california and
you mentioned you guys are getting this
influx of people and businesses uh does
that worry you ever that you know these
businesses come in they bring a whole
bunch of people they've often voted the
wrong way which caused the problems in
the first place and now they have to
integrate into a new state that is
basically doing it right
you know we hear that a lot the the
folks that we meet from california you
know i have those conversations with
them i jokingly tell them hey i had to
wait 18 years to vote in oklahoma so i
expect you to wait 18 years before you
can vote
and uh but they say they go hey listen
here's the deal there's there's 12
million people in california that voted
for president trump the people that are
leaving are recognizing the differences
between a blue state and a red state and
so trust me they're saying we are on
your side we believe in freedoms we
believe in smaller government we live in
less regulation doing business in
california is an absolute beat down i
know that personally and from the
regulatory climate from the taxation
climate they're just so out of touch
with what our values are as oklahomans
and most of americans that i think
normal people are leaving there if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell